welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is RV descrition as' who is visiting at
Yale as the Joseph pica zookas
postdoctoral associate in European
studies he is a researcher at CONUS
University of Technology professor
grisha's work centers on post-soviet
political identity formation in Central
and Eastern Europe today we'll talk with
him about his forthcoming book politics
with a human face identity and
experience in post-soviet Europe
welcome professor krishna thank you very
much but really let's start with an
overview of your book
tell us about it well it's a book that
summarizes my academic work so far it's
it incorporates some things that I was
interested back from my undergrad
studies and it just piled up and
developed into into a manuscript it's a
book about several things it it talks
about post-soviet political identity
formation how did the countries but more
important more importantly the people
who lived through the collapse of the
Soviet Union or or escaped the Soviet
Union as it was the case in the Baltic
States how did they later articulate
their political presence their you know
their their identity their sense of self
and sense of belonging to one political
sphere or the other so in the region
political identity has an existential
flavor if you like people had to react
you late there their presence I knew and
not only their political presence but
everyday life
profoundly so so it's very much related
to human experience everyday experience
and also with various kinds of ways that
this experience was articulated beaten
in some sort of political myths or
historical narratives or or bead and in
particular kinds of policies that
followed those those articulations so so
this book's tries to present an approach
how we can better understand these
processes in this central Eastern Europe
okay and what what countries are you
referring to well my work who builds
that theory or that approach on the
listening case okay and you are from
with me I am listening yes but it then
applies various aspects of the approach
for instance looks into political images
used in various other cases such as
Poland Estonia Ukraine Russia and a
couple of hours okay you know I enjoyed
you use some personal stories at the
beginning of the book and I enjoyed
reading them so if you could share some
of those with us and and how things
change for you specifically as a young
boy in Lithuania well when I grew up in
Lille I was born in 1987 so just before
lethwei Nia declared its independence in
1990 mark
well 11th of March 1990 and you know my
experience of this transition was of
course that of a child's but but still
it was filled with its sense of profound
change in all spheres of life you know
my gray environment my you know
blockhouse childhood was all of a sudden
filled with all these neon bright
plastic colors coming with cheap
merchandise from the West but travelling
through Turkey predominantly through
marketplaces in Turkey were people would
travel and buy these cheap
and bring them to 2:00 Eastern Europe it
it was filled with TV shows or films
like terminator yeah we had those you
know so all of a sudden you know it was
filled with various strange flavors you
know religious movements cultural
movements all kinds of new things that
that really put one out of balance and
and and people really didn't know what
to expect next to it it brought about
this very liminal as I call it a very
fluid transitional experience from in
which these these identities these
countries were forming so to me it's
very important that that kind of
atmosphere in which policies articular
are articulated identities are
articulated this I think it's very
important here ok and let's talk about
the theoretical approach you take in the
book tell us about that
right well because I'm talking about
what I call the human factor in politics
this this experiential imaginary aspects
of politics you know I talk about
political mythology and and historical
narratives and and human experiences I
had to develop my own vocabulary in a
sense and I took the majority of
concepts I use from cultural
anthropology or cultural studies and I
looked first of all at political culture
and the way people articulated politics
and try to explain it to to themselves
and saw the world so so it's very much a
cultural approach to to politics but
then it follows into explaining how
these are understandings these images
these these experiences how they
actually you know influence various
political choices for instance Athenian
advancement towards the European Union
and towards NATO was very much
reinforced by the certain worldview that
it had okay and in the besides the
besides Lithuania were there any
differences that you could see in any of
the country the other countries that you
looked at so what were they sure
probably the main differences in
relation to how people in in in
different countries articulate their
relationship with the Soviet Union so in
some countries you know the relationship
remain tight and remains tight even
nowadays with the Soviet past with the
previous ways of political culture in
others there was you know a bit of a
doubt there was playing back and forth
with that well for instance Ukraine
which only very recently made a decision
and still is pulled back and forth you
know it's however the very significant
detail that that I think kind of
indicates that shift in the narrative is
the collapse or the tearing down of
Lenin statues in the country so I might
be wrong but I know that there's a
there's not supposed to be any Lenin
statues left in public spaces in in the
parts of Ukraine not occupied but by
enemy forces but you know so this this
image of Lenin's all of a sudden begins
meaning more than just memory policy it
means the sphere of influence in a sense
a symbolic spear of influence so and on
some countries you know separated with
with that that's heritage long time ago
most
of course Baltic states right okay the
term human factor of politics let's talk
about that in a little bit more detail
right well the the as I mentioned before
it entails that not purely rationalistic
articulation of politics and well to me
politics is a human affair we often
think about it in very very strict
logical terms we we talk about interests
we talk about institutions and their
their legal interplay and and things
like that as if people were not involved
in in these processes and my my effort
is to show that the way the process
unfolds is actually structured by the
way people perceive world so through
culture through their experience through
their expectations and imagination so
what are some of the can you give some
concrete examples that you use in your
book to show these kinds of things well
if we get back to the Ukrainian example
the Maidan protests that took place in
2013 to 14 first of all we're called
euro Maidan and this beginning euro was
was important because it indicated a
certain teleology a certain image
towards which the protesters were
striving and that happened to be what
they imagined as the European Way of
life which counterpose to more more
Soviet
heritage and you know it was very
obvious in various visual
representations such as cartoons or
graffitis or you know comic depictions
of the present political situation
inside the territory of Maidan so these
imaginary depictions of the good the bad
the West the East they structured the
the the entire process they in a sense
inspired the movement so that's one
example another example could be also
well what's what's very important
nowadays it's the the populist and
nationalist movements we're a very
heavily some symbolism laden
emotionally-charged there they are not
functioning in the same way that that's
you know everyday politics function the
the function on on not very human but at
the same time very different plane of
associative thinking of emotional charge
of that kind of romantic intellectual
and and political charge so are you
saying for instance in the instance of
immigration which is such a huge topic
now in terms of the nationalistic views
of these countries in the Baltic States
how are you how is that playing into the
immigration situation well there there
have been as as you know many
refugees from from Syria were passing
passing the the central Eastern European
territories and and again the way they
were depicted the way they were tick you
lated in a sense shaped the way they
were treated yeah in those countries
places like Germany opened the borders
places like Hungary closed the borders
due to certain understandings of an
immigrant of another of difference and
also due to various historical memory
and experience and can you give any
other examples of how these human
factors have shaped politics
particularly in Lithuania well I
mentioned that Lithuania moved very
quickly towards the west and it was very
much you know predetermined one could
say by the way the Athenians imagined
and understood their present situation
well that that was in the 90s their
contemporary situation it you can see it
in any sources you take you beat
intellectual discourse where basically
the the way the independence movement
should act was discussed and and
determined or be its visual
representations of the situation so the
Soviet Union was depicted as a demon
Etrigan even you know blood sucking
beasts and and then the West was
considered first of all the homeland
because it connects to a Lithuanian
narrative of being being part of the
Europe and then being torn away from it
so returning to Europe they are
returning to Europe also has a
Christian world you know in opposition
to the atheist you know communist
totalitarian machine so so this binary
for instance was extremely important and
and it's structured the way politics
went not only during the independence
movement but afterwards as well we we
willingly joined the European Union
having received the sovereignty we
willingly gave it a part of it away to
you know participate in the European
community of nations yeah it's
fascinating to me how some countries as
you alluded to earlier really embraced
the European or Western Way why some
while some of the other countries kind
of still looked to the Soviet Union or
Russia for you know guidance can you
speak to why some countries and you know
didn't fully divest themselves from the
Soviet Union while others did well the
way I see it there's you know one thing
that is very important is whether or not
to the countries had some kind of
political independence in the interwar
period before the Soviet period and so
the Baltic States had that and then the
the constructed their post-soviet
identity based on that experience and
they had a direct reference also in
terms of of people actual generation of
people who lived in an independent
through theory yes previously and then
so the the narrative was of
re-establishing the identity rather than
constructing a new country and it's
important because then it's you know a
clear Tilly ology where do we go leads
to where we were right and we were in a
part of European countries another other
other countries had no such experience
or had very little experience like that
so that in in they seem to have lingo
more in in tight contact with the Soviet
past okay are there any remnants of the
Soviet Union in Lithuania today of
course yes of course that weighs well my
book kind of tries to tackle that
question but I I would say there's a
general culture of Soviet ISM the way I
call it throughout this the post-soviet
region and it entails several things one
being a strong emphasis on on the
victimhood experience on the on the
narratives and self self articulations
in terms of of experienced violence and
and some sort of sense of righteousness
there thereafter and it's it is true for
probably any post-soviet country that
you take another example is is the
imitation of the Western forms of
behavior but quite a superficial
imitation and there's even a broadly
known term for that or amount or euro
refurbishment you like which means you
know taking a let's say a socialist
communal flat well this does blockhouse
flat and adding this decorative sense of
fear of european habitat you know
through through quite cheap and poorly
picked materials through some sort of
having baroque to a blog house and and
you know a few things like that so
creatively let's call it adapting the
Western culture and quite quite bluntly
putting it as a decor for what is still
present as a result of that partial
result of that but also
due to the Soviet culture itself which
is which was double-faced the the the
things that were said in the newspaper
truth
Pravda were were completely different
from what was happening on on the ground
so that that kind of formed culture were
formality and actuality are two separate
things so in that regard the euro euro
refurbishment type of politics made
complete sense because this is how its
pursued okay so what do you conclude in
your book
well my conclusions are several and I
already mentioned a cup hole which is
some insights into the the way
post-soviet politics works another
conclusion is again that that point
about you know symbolic symbolic border
between between what I call Soviet and
post-soviet ists probably is the right
way of saying it and post-soviet
countries my argument is that in some
parts of central Eastern Europe Soviet
Union never ended or the narrative had
never transcended the logics of the
Soviet logic another point was also
about a couple of good positive aspects
of of post-soviet politics and namely
it's the local understanding of the
existential weight of politics it is in
the region that movements like charter
77 in Czechoslovakia solid Arnage in
Poland also the Lithuanian independence
movement scientists which were all
unarmed and peaceful political movements
for more genuine politics more
existentially clean politics you know
they were all inspired by by the
conditions that that the societies
and to exist in and I think this can be
a source of a positive change okay thank
you so much for being here with us today
thank you for more information about
Professor Grishin ascend his research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale.edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the Macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at you
you